okay now again hi and first of all thank
you for having me and thank you all for
being here my name is Manuel Matosevic
and I'm a freelance front-end developer
from Vienna the slides are already
online so you can check them out and
follow and log on your laptop if you
want to write I'm a way to put a badge
that was working on some JavaScript
stuff or you know actually I wasn't
working it was doing it just for fun
because I like to spend some of my free
time doing web stuff who else does that
who spends free time doing web stuff
yeah
some of us because we all love our job
or at least I do and I still love it
even though I'm doing this for quite a
while now I made my first web site about
17 years ago some friends and I were
playing an online game and we had a
so-called clan and I made the website
for his clan and that's the site the
name is in French the name is in French
and the translation is eat your poo we
were some badass 13 year olds yeah
definitely but our website was pretty
cool we had some image buttons and of
course a gap gas book and some Paul's I
informed users that the size was the
site was optimized for a certain
resolution and of course I had a marquee
tag here yeah
[Applause]
and there was even some custom
JavaScript stuff going on a few years
later I made my first personal website
there is a lot of embarrassing stuff
going on I'm not going to go into detail
later I even cut some stuff out because
it was just too much there are two very
interesting things here the first one is
one of my favorite favorite movies was
the shinning and the second thing is
that I didn't use CSS at all in this
website I made the layout with so called
frame sets some of you may know who them
yeah yeah frame set and I defined three
columns using HTML attributes and then I
embedded and in each of those columns
separates HTML file one for the
navigation one for the main content and
one for a sidebar for the layout of the
main content of course I used tables and
attributes like border color background
color align and I set the width to 442
percent it worked and for the global
styles of course I used again HTML
attributes like background color V link
and ailing for active and visited links
and the good old fonts tag for font size
and font family if I didn't use CSS
because maybe I didn't know about it or
maybe I just didn't need it but a few
years later in college I learned CSS and
all the great properties like float
position overflow background properties
line height and so on that was amazing
and then a few years later again I was
introduced to a game changer to CSS free
because all of a sudden we had
border-radius box shadow animation
transforms web fonts of course and the
way the web looked like changed
significantly and it still keeps
changing because browsers are can't
constantly shipping great new features
like flexbox grids feature queries
custom properties amazing stuff to
create amazing experiences but you know
what
spider-man's uncle says with great power
comes great responsibility
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and now we also have many tools to
create bad experiences and that's what I
want to talk about in the course of the
next twenty five minutes I'm going going
to show you some properties that you can
use in order to improve the
accessibility and the user experience of
your sites and some properties that you
can misuse in and change the experience
for the worse and I'm going to start
with font size the font size for text
was in the last few years somewhere
between 14 and 18 pixels that that has
changed recently and we can see more and
more sites increasing their font sizes
for example and CSS tricks a medium that
we have a font size of 21 pixels and
that's a good thing because 16 pixels
for text is definitely not good enough
or not big enough of course it depends
on the font you're using but starting
somewhere between 18 and 20 pixels is
probably a good thing and then working
your way up from there because usually
the bigger the screen size the bigger
the distance between the user and the
screen so for a usage on a smart TV for
example you would want to have a really
big font size so people can read still
read the text from a far distance next
thing line height the line height in
most browsers is at roughly 1.2 by
default the web accessibility initiative
recommends a line height of at least one
point five because for people with
cognitive disabilities it's easier to
start a new line after they have
finished the previous one if the line
height is bigger and on top of that if
you compare the two the second one looks
even nicer if the because of the bigger
line Heights
text is by default aligned to the left
or to the right depending on the reading
direction of the language and a thing
designers like to do is to justify the
text because justifying text makes
especially long text look nicer because
all lines have the same length what the
browser does in order to get those same
length lines is that increases/decreases
the word spacing and this may result in
irregular word spacing and for some
people it's harder to read text if the
word spacing is irregular and on top of
that a friend of mine recently told me
that using justified text in web design
is so 2016 so it's bad for accessibility
and it's not cool so just don't do it
please Dennis told me to say please here
we have a nice paragraph the line height
is all rights the font size is all
rights but something is odd about this
paragraph it's just too narrow not
enough words fit per line it's it's hard
to read on the other hand in this
paragraph the text is just too long the
paragraphs is too wide what's considered
ideal is a character count between 45
and 75 characters per line so that's
considered ideal yes so here for example
we have a paragraph with a maximum
maximum of about 65 characters per line
it looks nice and it's easy to read
what's cool about that is that we can
use CSS to control that we can set a max
width of this paragraph to 65 characters
the character unit has been around for
quite a while now and it's pretty cool
it represents the width of the glyph
zero in the elements font and this
paragraph for example here will only be
as big as to fit 65 characters roughly
65 characters per line so that's pretty
cool
we have or there are several pseudo
elements you can use in CSS to create
cool things two of the more popular ones
are before and after you can use before
to add content directly after the start
tag and after to add content directly
before the end tag we can do cool to
stuff we can do cool stuff using those
pseudo elements but there is one thing
we shouldn't do we should not add text
using CSS text belongs in an HTML file
coming from that database or API but it
shouldn't be in CSS what we can do is we
can add icons or glyphs using CSS for
example here this code will produce this
nice-looking X and I've used this X here
to create a custom list I've removed the
default list styling and I've added
spans in each list item with this X and
if the sound works we are going to hear
how the screenreader jaws on Windows is
going to read this list
okay doesn't matter it will it will say
Times item 1 times item 2 times item 3
times item 4 because as it turns out
this X isn't the X but the symbol four
times like in two times two or three
times four and this can get very
confusing because users might think that
we are multiplying all those list items
but in reality we're just using it as a
design feature as a bullet so what you
want to do here is you want to make sure
that you hide those things semantically
this means that it's still visually
visible but hidden for screen readers
and you can do that by using the area
hidden attribute and setting it to true
and by the way in this example don't do
that what I just showed you you would
rather stick to the good old list I'll
type all this tile image for changing
these icons is more accessible now a
nice topic for today color contrast
color contrast is important because of
conferences and because 285 million
people are visually impaired 39 million
are blind and 246 have low vision 7 to
12 percent of men and less than 1% of
women have some form of color vision
deficiency it's usually hard for them to
differentiate two colors like red and
green now the reason why color contrast
is important is that people deem their
screens on their smartphones for example
and people like to use their smartphones
outside even when the sun is shining so
we know color contrast is important but
how much is enough the web accessibility
initiative defines it by enough contrast
between text and its background so that
so that it can be read by people with
moderately low vision okay we got that
but you know we need in a number we need
a way to measure that and there is one
they got so called contest contrast
ratio the lowest ratio is one to one you
get that if you use the same color for
text and background the highest ratio is
1 to 21 you get that if you use black
text on white background and vice versa
the minimum ratio for normal texts we
would like to achieve for normal text
that is less than 25 pixels is for 0.5
to 1 and the minimum ratio for bold text
that is less than 19 pixels is 3 to 1
and for larger text it's also three to
one
that's the absolute minimum ideally you
would have a ratio of 7 to 1 for normal
text and 4.5 to 1 for bold text of
course there are ways to measure the
ratio for example there's one in the
browser made by leave a room you can
enter here on the left side the
background color and on the right side
the text color and it will give you the
score for example here we have a ratio
of 3.2 to 1 which is not enough but you
can change that and try some other
colors and the score will update and
here for example we have a score of 15
point 3 to 1 which is very good
another way of testing accessibility is
possible with deaf tools in Chrome
starting with Chrome 60 lighthouse is
baked in in chrome dev tools in an audit
panel and you can check your sites for
several best practices for PWO PWA best
practices accessibility performance and
general press best practices lighthouse
will check your sites and give you a
score and it will list all the things
that aren't alright and it for example
here it will tell you which elements
don't have enough enough contrast so
that's pretty nice another great thing
is that you can display the color ratio
directly in the color picker in chrome
dev tools that's not possible in
standard chrome you have to get Chrome
Canary enable experiments and you have
to press shift seven times and then you
really have to do that and then you have
to check the setting and that's it now
measuring is one thing but actually
testing is another thing again there are
ways for us to test contrast ratios and
so on for example in Windows you can
enter the settings and you will find
high contrast settings and you can
switch the default theme of Windows to a
very high contrasting theme for example
like this one or this one or you can
also set your own colors here and I did
that and I made a very simple example
okay the contrast it's better now very
simple example it's based on something I
found in dribble it's something like a
login form and I used it in several high
contrasting themes and this is what it
looks like what you can see here is that
the button isn't recognizable anymore
you see it's entered text but you don't
see that it is a button and if it wasn't
for the placeholder text you wouldn't
see the input fields they would be
invisible a really quick fix for me was
to add default borders for the input
fields and the buttons and now the
accessibility is much much better for
those for this simple form in high
contrast modes of course there was there
was
just quick fix there's a lot more to it
Annika hanker wrote a very awesome
article about that and I'm going to
share it with my slides later on another
great tool is called no coffee
it's a browser plugin there you can set
several things for example you can make
the site blurry or you can simulate
color deficiencies or you can even
simulate blocked visual fields so there
are a lot of things you can do in this
settings panel here to test stuff again
it's called no coffee the reason why I'm
talking about contrasts I guess you know
the reason but one of the reason when
reasons why I'm talking about contrast
is there has been a certain trend of
using low contrasting colors in web
design something like a grey on grey
text color on light grey backgrounds
now this might look nice but it's very
inaccessible and I'm pretty sure that
there are other colors than gray and
light gray that look nice believe it or
not but people are still printing stuff
out and people are even printing
websites people are printing contact
information directions recipes articles
pretty much everything and we should try
to give them at least some kind of
experience in that that's actually
pretty easy all you have to do is to
define a at media block in your CSS
similar to media queries and then change
all the items you want to look
differently on paper for example if you
have a fixed header you can set it to
static on paper or you can also maybe
hide the navigation because it's
probably pretty useless on paper
who would fall another thing you can do
maybe is to by default hide everything
or air it direct child item of the body
except for the main content so hiding
the header and the footer and one thing
that's pretty cool about the print
medium is that we can use absolute units
like centimeter or millimeter and point
just makes sense you shouldn't use that
on a web but on paper it makes
absolutely sense something that special
about print is that links are
unfortunately useless you can click them
you can try but you yeah it wouldn't
work but there is a thing we can do to
make them at least to put at least some
use in links on paper and that's it's
this selector here we can select all
links that start with HTTP this includes
HTTP as well but it doesn't include
relative paths or anchor links and then
we make sure that we don't includes
absolute links to our site and then we
use the after pseudo elements to adds
the content of the href attribute in
parentheses right next to the text so
this paragraph here will look like this
on screen and on paper it will look like
this so the value of the href attribute
is printed next to the word it's not
perfect but it's something
if you are like me you like to use the
keyboard sometimes for navigation on the
website for example if you're filling
out a long form because it's easier to
jump from one form iron to another if
you use the keyboard the tab key
sometimes that works great and sometimes
that doesn't work at all because we as
developers are pretty good at doing bad
things to form items we are let me show
you some of those things here we have
two buttons when I click the first
button and alert pops up great if I
click this second button the alert pops
up as well and now I'm going to use the
tab key to focus those buttons I can
focus the first one but I can't focus
the second one the reason for that is
that the first button is an html5
pattern element the second button is a
DIF that looks like a button and divs
aren't focusable of course you can add
the tabindex attribute and make it 4
focusable but if you are already using
the keyboard you would probably want to
do everything with the keyboard also
triggering this event by clicking space
or enter and you can only do that on the
button because we get those key events
for free with the button element that
just does just doesn't work on it if of
course you can add those events manually
but why would you if you just could use
button so please use button if you need
about another bad thing is here with a
nice looking form and now you are going
to see which keys I'm pressing right
next to the form
[Music]
did you see that no you didn't because
that's in my CSS I'm selecting all items
in this page in their focus state and
I'm setting the outline to none but just
using those free lines I'm excluding a
whole group of people from being able to
use my sites
if I remove those free lines you will
see this now all of a sudden we can see
where we are in the forum because we get
this nice blurry blue line outline now
the reason why designers and developers
remove this blue outline in the first
place is it's just actually just doesn't
look nice and on top of that it's very
inconsistent across browsers so for
example here on Chrome we will get this
blue outline on Firefox you will get a
dotted outline and on Android for
example a solid orange outline so it
kind of makes sense to remove it but if
you do provide at least some kind of
alternative styling you can use your
branch colors and use solid borders
background color
link text color whatever it is just some
kind of focus stars and again you can do
it by using the focus of the class or
you can use some of the newer stuff for
example here this form only this place
the border if one of its children has
focus so it's not the form itself that
it's focused but one of its child items
and that's possible using the focus
within pseudo class it's pretty new
support is okay
but you can use it now if you're not
using it for anything too critical I
guess one thing that's annoying about
focus tiles is that sometimes they are
displayed when you don't want them to be
displayed for example if you're using
the mouse so here for example we have a
custom tab component and you can see the
outline when I'm using the keyboard but
now I'm going to click the tabs or the
panels and it's still visible and this
is not just annoying but also can be
very distracting to Mouse users so what
we need is a way to differentiate
between keyboard and mouse users and
that's possible using the focus ring
pseudo-class focus ring pretty much does
the same thing as focus but it only
applies those those Styles when it makes
sense and the browser decides when it
makes sense so we don't have to do much
more unfortunately it only works in
Firefox right now but but there is a
very lightweight polyfill that you can
use check it out try it and maybe also
give feedback to the people who made it
so who are we making this for who are we
making
focused odds for of course for us the
power users who would like to use the
keyboard on long forms but especially
for people who actually rely on the
keyboard is the only way of navigation
for example a person with just one arm
or maybe someone who would actually use
the mouse but can't because he or she
broke their arm or maybe also a new
parent who's holding the baby and has to
check something out online so it's
important for us to know that there are
permanent temporary and situational
impairments and this makes the group of
potential keyboard users for example
much much bigger
I took the graphics of the inclusive
design guide by Microsoft it's pretty
cool check it out all right it's now I'm
going to talk about some of the newer
stuff here about grids we have a list of
images here and I want to lay them out
in a nice-looking grid that's pretty
easy with CSS grid layouts I just said
that this beta grid I define as many
columns as fit the screen with a minimum
width of 180 pixels I add some spacing
vertical and horizontal spacing and I
said a default height for all rows in
these grids so four lines of CSS
and we get this pretty awesome and it's
of course also completely responsive so
that's nice by the way the images are
scaled so nicely because I'm using
object fits Sara mentioned that in her
talk the only thing that's not right
here is that we lost the different image
sizes we had big and long images we can
fix that I'm going to select all the
long and the large images and I'm going
to make them spend two rows and then I'm
selecting the large images and make them
span two columns and I'm going to place
the first one at the very end of our
grids and the last one at the very
beginning to make it look a little nicer
and this is what we get due to the
implicit implicit placement at it and
the different image sizes we get those
gaps we can try to work around that
there is a property called grid Auto
flow and if you set value to dense the
browser will try to fill those gaps and
this is what we get six lines of CSS and
of course also completely responsive
this is super super super awesome and it
sucks let's see what happens if you try
to use the keyboard on this gallery so
the first image is focused now and I'm
pressing tab okay
oh where we going okay that's all right
which one is okay this one mm-hmm so
since the browser reordered the items
the visual order isn't anymore the same
order as Dom order and that's bad for
keyboard users because there's no way of
knowing which item is going to be
focused next don't get me wrong
please use grid and use everything grid
has to offer it's really really awesome
but just be careful when you're using it
on very interactive interaction
sensitive stuff like forms prop no don't
use no forms but on galleries or stuff
like that this of course doesn't just
apply to grid but to pretty much any
property that affects order in some way
like flexbox position floats negative
margins and so on all right okay since
we are at a topic of grid who of you has
already used grids
okay some people who used it in
production okay you're cool you cool do
it it's awesome all major Brown major
browsers that ester browsers are
supported even edge since a week yeah or
a few days so all major tester browsers
are supported of course they're still IE
10 and 11 and older edge but you can
still use it thanks to the power of
progressive enhancement you can provide
a very basic version of your site for
example using floats and then enhance it
with grids let me show you a demo to
illustrate what I mean by that here we
have a very simple single column layout
it doesn't look nice because it's on a
large screen but that's pretty much what
would you what you would get on a
smartphone that's not very nice but it's
alright I can enhance that by using
float and now we have a layout it's
boring but it works we can enhance it
some more using flexbox and now
especially the lower part gets a little
more interesting so that's pretty cool
and then we can enhance it some more and
to whatever we want because grids and
what's cool about that is that we don't
have to write 3 or 4 different versions
of a site we just provide this basic
layout using floats and then we put grid
on top of that because properties like
display:inline-block display tab will
sell column properties floats don't work
on flags or grid items they just don't
have any effect so you don't have to
override them for browsers that support
grids they just simply don't do anything
anymore if the if they're applied to a
grid or flex item the only time where
you have probably have to use feature
queries is when you override widths or
margin something like that so that's
pretty cool and grid is cool but it also
introduces a new temptation let me show
you what I mean let's say we want to
build something like that we have a
heading and six items here
and the HTML may look like this so we
have a div and a heading an unordered
list and those six items I'm going to
use this big grid here again I'm going
to create those free columns I'm setting
a gap again and I'm placing the heading
and this is what we get
of course because only direct child
items of a grid container are laid out
in a grid and the direct child items are
the h2 and unordered list the worst
thing you can do is to remove the
unordered list and transform all the
divs to lists I add all the list items
divs you should not compromise on
semantics for design or deaf experience
reasons don't do that please please what
you could do is to good use display sub
grids
if you apply to an unordered list the
list items will behave as if they were
direct child items of the div themselves
unfortunately display subgrid didn't
make it into level one of the
specification but it will probably come
with level two I don't know when but we
hope another thing you could do is to
set the display to contents the contents
will make the lists list items behave as
if their parent the unordered list
didn't exist at all so they would behave
as if they were direct child items of
the grid container yeah no Firefox again
is the only browser that supports that
so what you ultimately have to do is to
define another grid in this unordered
list so again these blue grids three
columns and gap I know that's not cool
but it's it's something since the
unordered list has the same width as the
container you can make it span all three
columns and just inherit all the
properties so you can inherit all the
disparate properties it's a little nicer
yeah whatever it is you do don't flatten
the structure don't do that
of course that's not everything you have
to know about CSS and accessibility but
it's also more than just a starting
point let's say you take two of the
things I showed you today and care about
them in your next project you are
already doing a really great job and if
you take two more things and apply the
in your next project you are working
towards a better more inclusive and more
open web it's important that we as
designers and developers don't just
design and make websites for the way we
are using it we must not assume that our
users are using a certain operating
system input device browser or device
and as my mentor Aaron Gusterson said
designing with constraints in mind is
simply designing well I know mother was
a lot but there is a written form of
this article online on medium that of
this talk online on medium and I can
recommend a very awesome book by Hayden
Pickering it's called inclusive design
patterns I even have it with me so if
you want to take a look feel free to
meet me afterwards again the slides are
online thank you very much
[Applause]